[Music]
welcome back to another awesome episode
of the care for boys and we got walter
hong here today walter
a little prompt we're talking about
during the break we're going to talk
about the first time you either got into
a fight or you got your ass beat um um
first time i got into a fight
and what do they count if it's just like
elementary school fights it better
that's when it first yeah because that's
the only thing in elementary that's when
i first started
the first time i ever got my ass beat um
was in first grade
so like it was really shocking because
you know when you're a kid you don't
even even know what violence is like you
might mess around with your friends
you're just kind of going like this
whatever i remember um
i was playing with uh i was playing at
my friend's house he went inside this is
his little brother actually his little
brother is pretty big we got into like a
pushing kind of
match
and then he just kicks me in the face
and i remember my lips just burst open
and blood just starts coming out but
i've never experienced violence from
anyone outside of my parents before
you've never been punched by anybody who
wasn't your dad for example he's like
this is so weird i just stood there i
didn't even know what to do and he kept
kicking him in the face over and over
and over and over so you're just
standing there yeah boom oh my god i
just froze i didn't know what the [ __ ]
to do and then i went home and i was
just crying i was balling and [ __ ] and
that was like the first time that i was
like
holy [ __ ] that sex is crazy and in all
seriousness did your dad kick your ass
because you got your ass kicked no my
parents were divorced already but my
aunt who's my mom's little sister was
staying with us at the time and she was
like if someone ever touches you you hit
them back i was okay i understand that's
a good ant
have you have you seen have you seen
that kid she died in a fight
have you seen that have you seen that
kid since then no no no oh you don't
want to look him up and find him do the
same thing i don't even remember his
name this is like when i was six i am
that petty the walter i'm just as pretty
as you are my friend yes i don't yeah i
don't even remember the kids it's like i
don't remember his name goes to his
house giant shrine dude every [ __ ]
news clip with [ __ ] thread everywhere
on push pins it's like magruber kfbr of
392.
and what sucks is he was the rich kid in
our neighborhood so he's already the kid
all right that family is already the kid
that had everything you know he was a
kid that like their family had like the
200 000 rv parked in the drive like they
just that was like the the family in the
neighborhood had everything
and he whipped my ass well you could
have nowadays you just sue that kid then
you guys are [ __ ] gucci yeah that's
right you give me the rv yeah thanks
we'll take the rv let's go to uh fights
in the category i wish you were
conscious and understood the experience
and like you know what i mean like the
emotions and the nerves so my friend had
a sleepover i must i don't even [ __ ]
know i was in virginia at the time so i
was like fourth grade
and like it was super cool because like
there's a sleepover and we're all at his
house and like there's there's girls
there right it's like they don't get to
stay for the sleepover but they're for
his birthday okay so yeah in the in the
basement versus where we all got to hang
out like we organized like some fights
or whatever the [ __ ] and like dude
fourth grade kids fighting is not real
fighting ever but i had done taekwondo
and [ __ ] so i was like dude i got some
moves and [ __ ] i said i could do a front
flip because i
i could do a front flip not kidding i
could because i think my legs were long
enough i could just do a [ __ ] front
flip
um
is it the ones where you touch your hand
and you flip forward that's a handspring
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm not a gymnast
dude are you talking about when you go
on your side
walter i will fight you right now bro
i'll do one on your [ __ ] body right
now are you talking about where you're
rolling
i was trying to match what you give me
hey but if we if we fight don't kick me
in the balls because i might get hard
[Laughter]
so no so i was like dude i got the moves
to show off these stupid chicks right
and then yeah we're in the basement and
dude it's the best part about it is it's
just dudes throwing each other down
[ __ ]
yeah
you throw the other guy down and he's
like yay
yeah yeah and like you're trying to show
off in front of the girls exactly
and then my friend joel he wiped his
butt on the american flag and i'll never
forget it because we're all like that's
[ __ ] up
but he's just like yeah there's american
flag in the basement and he like took it
and wiped it on his butt but you thought
that was a real fight like you guys were
like doing it well no this is that's the
fight it was his party so we're all like
white people are crazy because like no
minority would ever
dude joel was jewish dude don't even
worry about it don't even worry
they're white too
i haven't heard that lately oh yeah
though they're they're white oh whoopi
ever since whoopee i haven't heard that
yeah ever since
what's known as the black israelite
can you believe she's a goldberg and
like people are like yo that's [ __ ] up
what you said that's like all right leah
goldberg bro she's like she's fine she's
fine she's not anticipating i'm actually
homburg but we shortened our name to
hong kong
walter homburg jerome greenberg no i'm
not i'm a loser greenberg's would be
very successful though very successful
name so i have a story picking back off
that but it was i was a freshman summer
chilton no no front flips high school no
yeah i was a freshman i had like gotten
in fights a little bit here and there
but it was always like someone [ __ ]
with me and then like i would like
we would kind of fight but it was always
there were always like kind of [ __ ]
about it so it was like i never really
got in a fight this is before you
started training this before i started
training um so i was my freshman year
was a water polo team i guess my water
polo coach at the time would like box i
don't know if he was any good i don't
think he was he a real boxer
he wanted a shadow boxer i think he was
one of those guys like i think he was
one of those that's like because i would
see him later in my years actually
fighting and he would actually come in
the gym and i was like oh i don't think
this guy used to box
so and so he would get the varsity team
i was on the junior varsity team the
freshman team he would make us go in the
weight room and like box each other
and i remember at the time i was like
yeah and i had a box like a senior or
something his name was austin he was
like a really nice guy but he was like
he was like really quiet but kind of
like strong and dude i was like 112
pounds oh [ __ ] i was like nothing you
know and i was like oh yeah i got in
like some fights in middle school like
i'll be fine i'm gonna like beat this
dude's ass and i was like yeah dude i
just do karate like man i'ma kick this
dude's [ __ ] ass we square off all i
remember was i have my gloves up
i just got hit once
and then i woke up from the floor
wow dude and then i don't really
actually i i
the first one i got hit like on my face
and then i was like whoa and then i just
remember waking up a couple weeks ago i
made fun of you saying the expert in
this room on getting knocked out is this
man and you're like i never been knocked
out yeah and actually when you brought
this prompt i remembered this right on
the spot
but
as far as like in my in my training
career i haven't but i was like a
freshman probably
i just wake up and i just see all these
faces around me they're like hey man
good job and i was like yeah you guys
think so cool man all right cool and
then that was it good job on getting
knocked the [ __ ] out hey nice job
getting laid out dude
the way i fell you felt gracefully
through the first
memory of like a legit fight for me
was probably third grade right or fourth
grade but anyways i was in san francisco
because my um
uncle is a pastor of a church out there
so i made friends with one of the kids
that went to that church
and so there was uh it was at a house
like they they built a church where you
know one of those like full house house
looking places and in the backyard we
would just play and he had a [ __ ]
truck that he was messing with
and something happened where we were
like fighting over it right
and then
we went we started shoving we started
like scrapping and stuff and he grabbed
my head [ __ ] kneed me
in the face oh my god he started crying
and running away after he did that and i
was like pissed because i'm like i
didn't get to [ __ ] really fight like
i didn't even you just grabbed me and
[ __ ] kneed my face my cousin was
watching the whole thing and i thought
he was gonna come over here and he was
gonna like lay the smack down like don't
[ __ ] with my cousin and all this stuff
right and he just goes man i'm so
disappointed in you oh [ __ ]
you started scolding me like you didn't
even [ __ ] you let him [ __ ] you let
him knee your face dude kind of [ __ ]
up and that's probably one of the
biggest things that i just i was like
[ __ ] man i let him down like i looked up
to my cousin and i'm like damn he's not
gonna take me to [ __ ] hate street
anymore dude
[Laughter]
looking up to cousins is such a mistake
by the way yeah for real what a letdown
hippies are man
don't ever look up to cousins ever
so we don't end on a shitty you know
story or anything like that i'll all go
next
wait this is careful boys we're halfway
through what is it is it because you
have you won you actually won or
something no because i've actually i
have a lot of fights i've never been in
a fight in my life what never been i've
been in like push-arounds and then like
it's about to happen how come we never
been in a fight dude i'm a [ __ ]
dancer man like we [ __ ] fight we
battle with music and then hug
afterwards you've been a dance fight to
have your back right now yeah no i've
really never been in a fight i feel like
i was always like either a [ __ ] or a
pacifist either or depend depends on who
you talk to what if someone like steps
to you just talk your way out of it
you're [ __ ] way he's smooth how
smooth this guy is i honestly
i don't think anybody's ever wanted or
needed to beat my ass for i'll beat your
[ __ ] ass bro he was an eagle scout
i'm so surprised no one tried to kick
your ass did other eagle scouts protect
you is that what it was
in our era right in our era you walk
down the hallway someone shoulder bumps
you that's a fight a lot of that did
happen but i always ended up just either
like walking away from him just moonwalk
away or what the [ __ ] he gets hit and
then just keeps going
that's crazy a lot of a lot of random
pushing and shoving where it seems like
it's about to escalate or like talking
[ __ ] to the next guy regardless or
standing up to somebody who you know is
gonna beat your ass yeah and then
getting stopped in some way but like i
for some reason just never got into it
were you ever in a parking garage though
and you guys like
basically his [ __ ] war dude i can't
believe you even know how to snap your
fingers by the way thank you it's like
am i the jet or are you the shark i
don't know which one you guys didn't
[ __ ] tie your arms together and
[ __ ] dance with a knife and [ __ ] i
didn't realize how [ __ ] entertaining
this was gonna be i was like i've never
been in a fight let's move on everybody
here just like wow today's video is
brought to you by feels cbd isn't about
what you feel it's about what you do not
feel such as stress anxiety pain all the
nasty feelings in your heart sometimes
at night you know you're trying to go to
sleep and you're like oh man i'm still
amped either from a workout or i had a
stressful day or you just want to chill
and if you're like me you drink a little
bit of alcohol and start throwing up all
over the place you're like how can i
chill with this person i call my wife
hmm she seems to drink alcohol okay
maybe i'll take a little cd so we could
both be relaxed and you put a little
couple of drops underneath your tongue
or if you like the gel method put in
your hot tea and you drink it i stink it
like that and you feel chill
it's a super easy process but i get it
if it's intimidating they have a hotline
that you can call and be like hey check
it out i never used cbd before no
judgment help me out here uh what is the
recommended dose right because you don't
know if you want to take a bunch and you
get super sleepy or you just need a few
drops and if you want to save a little
bit of money and you don't want to order
every single month you could join their
membership and they'll send it to you
every single month with a discount you
can cancel in any time that's right so
become a member today go to fields.com
off the record to save 50 off your first
order plus free shipping that's
feels.comfeals.com
off the record to get 50 off plus free
shipping
were you always tall like people scared
or something no actually in high school
i was five two in the beginning wait did
you go to all girls school
because even girls will fight you
[Applause]
there were more girl fights in my high
school than guy fights you know you ever
see girls fight and they just go right
at it they go to the hair
and they tear the cl they take off the
clothes girls will punch and they'll go
in punching because they don't
understand how hard they because they
don't hit hard but guys will like dance
around because we know how hard guys hit
but like girls don't know like i've seen
a girl fight where one her friend's
holding the girl and she you know they
don't have accuracy so she's punching
her friend
if it was a guy doing that like if one
of you guys were hitting me i'd be like
knocked out well not him anthony be like
[Laughter]
dude this girl's like starts laughing
let me see her front flip steve hey i'll
do it actually don't don't tempt me dude
don't tempt me [ __ ] do it i'm tough
to you you gotta pay for my hospital
bill i'll give you a little right now
nikki's gonna get pissed we're gonna
take these to the hospital yeah yeah
yeah we still need a couple more days
with steve yeah i'll do it on sunday
[ __ ]
sunday 5 30 p.m let's go i want someone
to understand how long legs help a front
flip i would think short legs help a
front foot because there's less i'm very
i was very very very thin right and so
long legs
uh could propel me upwards but then the
yeah the the uh the landing was always a
[ __ ]
always a [ __ ]
i'm like a cricket but uh you know i
don't have the the other uh appendages
to land with that's what i was thinking
but i'm like is this dude right now
trying to tell us he's better than us
because he's white and he has long legs
we have short legs because if you do a
front flip long legs it is a detriment
no no
the the
power the power yeah helpful he's now
you say white people are stronger than
we are this is
at least you're not uh you know
bringing your own insecurities into this
meanwhile
there is one famous white guy with short
legs like asian people michael phelps
does he have short legs
he has long torso he seems very tall
like tyrion lannister like ian edwards
has this ian edwards has this great joke
about it
he's like you know you ever notice like
you know asian dudes have short legs and
then like when they they're sitting down
and when they stand up they're the same
height as when they were there
that's pretty spot on i like freaking
ian dude
but yeah michael phelps is the same way
long torso short legs yeah [ __ ] michael
phelps what about your fights yeah
what's your fight so i was like up to i
think third fourth grade i was bullied a
lot like physically um and then my
parents put me in um there was a they
didn't put me taken first they put me in
um tiger yang muya dough what is that
yang used to be a martial art actor but
he created his own martial art muya do
and he said he's tempted to be black
belt and people started complaining
there's no such thing so he lowered it
to ninth degree
so but i learned from him like but so
were you were you learning stunt
fighting it's like fake fighting
a mixture of all the different martial
arts that he allegedly was excelled at
you know and then um
so i remember in fourth grade this tall
dude i remember his name still david
ragsdale
uh it was this tall white guy shout out
that's why you have a problem with tall
white guys
this guy could actually flip and he had
long legs it was weird and so you know
we got in the pushing match and then
like
i you know i thought i'm gonna get my
butt kick but whatever but i threw a
kick right at his face but i didn't kick
him though it was right at his face and
then we just kind of stopped whoa he was
like what's going on you mean like one
of those like he had a cigarette and you
put it out yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
like one of those things morning shot
yeah it was like more like a warning
shot because this is like in fourth
grade but you meant to hit but you
actually missed but it worked out
actually you know as i don't know if i
meant to hit him i think i just meant
i'm just gonna do this
and let's just see what happens yeah
yeah and then usually that scares people
though and then i later i got the
taekwondo and then i got better at it
and then i remember i think it was like
in fifth grade because i was small and
fifth grade i was the fourth smallest in
class
like i don't mean just boys i mean like
boys and girls wow and i was waiting in
line for handball
and then this dude comes over i remember
his name jonathan derby he pushes me out
of line and he takes my foot he takes my
place and then so i gave him a front
kick right in the stomach and he tried
to hit me he and then that's that's when
his breath caught up to him he's like
and then i was
like
teacher came we both got in trouble yeah
i was like i love that yeah
sixth grade or seventh grade oh [ __ ]
front kick to the stuff yeah i'll give
it a fight that'll do it girl knock her
honestly because you know they do the
push kicks now yeah the push kick is
more for hollywood because it looks cool
but that doesn't do much it just pushes
them away but a front kick
with the toes right right in the little
snapback honestly very underrated very
underrated defense tactic so in sixth
grade or seventh grade i'm gonna bet you
know the first and last you're a petty
[ __ ] walter and i like that
about you you know petty's a strong word
oh i'm petty i own it i just remember
everything yeah
people don't forget
i just remember everyone i'm not like
bart bart's a forgiving man he doesn't
remember the kid's name i don't remember
his name i got [ __ ] lists yeah no
bart's too insecure now he he actually
built on his insecurities and he built
out like his own his own form yeah
turned it into muscle yeah
no me glass house
i gotta write down all the names i gotta
remember this [ __ ] wait we're where's
steve buscemi in um is it billy madison
um um is billy madison where they had
the list and he was knocking off oh like
he was assassin and then he was like oh
cause he had a list of people that
offended him yeah yeah was that billy
madison no no and then he said sorry and
then he came back and then yeah and then
he
adam sandler said sorry and he took him
off the list yeah
um yeah and then i think in sixth or
seventh grade i got to fight playing
basketball with this guy
he was one of the rich witcher kids and
he was smart too rich and smart and so
he kind of threw that in everyone's face
i remember his name too alberto and um i
remember
and then like i took him to the ground
and i remember smashing his head on the
concrete oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] not too wear
like you know the only what made it
worse was um
his friend was trying to like pull me
off of him and then i was one of the
first kids that were boxers so i got
made fun of they're always wearing
boxers that's a cool thing though but
back then when i was a kid like you know
it was a cool thing but if you're the
first one to do anything oh you know and
then so that made me more mad and then
like um i think he was trying to like
scratch
scrunch my face or whatever but that
made me more mad and then um
then like i think something like in
junior high and junior high like yeah i
but i never like i beat everyone but
like in high school
yeah i beat everybody up but in high
school because koreans stopped growing
between eighth and ninth grade like we
just stopped there's anomalies of course
but we stopped growing but when i got to
the highest i realized yo
none of this taekwondo stuff's gonna
work because this dude is six two and
he's the same age as you and they're
huge you know and they're benching like
three of you yeah and so like yeah that
my fighting career i had i don't think
i've been into a fight i don't think i
fought oh you just you just walk out of
it i'm sorry
i just do it
just kidding
and then like you know and then in
college i think i got into some scraps
but it was more intimidation than
anything else like i'm fighting and then
as an adult
i just i asked like open-ended questions
like so like let's say like you wanted
to fight with me i'll be like are you
serious
which that forces him to explain
you know like
that's a great de-escalation yes just
keep asking questions what's the
following you say are you serious yes
then what why why not like what's this
gonna do because you're a dick and then
i'll say you know what i guarantee you
if we fight one of us is gonna end up in
jail and one's gonna end in the hospital
that's so reasonable wow i don't wanna
end up in any of those you're a peaceful
man you're a piece of man of peace and
then a fighter told me he goes dude if
you think you you might get into a fight
like always have your hands by your face
no that's wrong you could block easy you
could block easier you got to pull your
pants down
that d is clear and then you go
and then you just run after them and
they run but what i can't take is the
laughter that that's it hurts no i'm not
not beard oh okay so i went too far i
went too far take down your pants and go
i play for keeps dude
if i win you lose [ __ ] if i win
guess what happens next dude you don't
yeah i give you two guesses the first
one doesn't count steve taught me that
yeah that's true dude that's true i
didn't think about that but i don't know
i'm afraid if i pull everything down
they're like hey why do you have a
vagina
but then that's another open-ended
question
but the key i think is asking open-ended
questions i think so you know because
you know like i asked it sometimes on
stage like who's a who's a tough guy and
you know guys always raise their hand
who the [ __ ] who raises there right here
this guy [ __ ] let's go
exactly the people you think of raise
your hand exactly who you think of right
and then i always say that and then i'll
say like dude okay like you know i don't
know when the last fight you were in you
know but who's fought in the last year
people some people raise their hand
and then you know you guys train there
yeah you know we train but why though
like why like if you're living your life
where you're getting into fights
regularly you need to change something
especially
and there's always gonna be someone
tougher than you like a fight better
than you and once you get your butt
whipped you know i don't wanna fight no
more i won't do anything you know and
like now i can't kick high like i can
kick someone's knees but that's about it
you know it's pretty good that's all you
got to do i know if i do i'll miss
like i'll just miss my accuracy this is
the best guys this is the clobber
technique
that's it man i'll tell them i made up
my own martial art called wanango it's
all it's about circular motion right
yeah so like if you punch everything you
block and you turn it it was all
circular and then the guy my friend goes
okay let me do it fast no no no this is
how fast we go because this this is it
this is all slow dude and then people
like this guy's crazy
that works i heard almost everything you
said but i was just picturing myself
doing front flips the whole [ __ ] time
landing them
[Music]
you